hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to point perfect the rage
can do see little rage inducing game
that is supposed to be very very
difficult because it is very very
precise and it also features retro
sounds music and graphics that you may
enjoy now okay starting in three toe one
I've never even played the hell was that
don't tell me there's some secret horror
game here
alright so either greed vitality or
utility Oh guess that I need increased
points per second so I'm gonna go with
greed bring it on I have no idea how to
play I'm a complete noob I don't know
what the hell I'm doing okay oh okay
alright this is gonna be impossible
I can't wait to fail over and over again
for you guys so I can't oh okay thank
you mister Skellington so not only can I
not make the box too big
I can't you rule I can't click over
people because it'll kill me one use
increased targeting full power gray for
me what does that do okay I took it I
don't know what's happening what what do
you mean wait what I don't know what's
going on wait a minute what but if my
other game was over there wait a minute
is like permanent death or something
okay so I'm guessing I gotta set up
traps for these douches okay aha okay
okay so come walk into my trap walk into
my okay I'm getting it everybody I'm
getting on I'm gonna I'm starting to
understand I'm starting to understand
that this game is a bit of a bastard but
I got it see my skillet game is actually
incredible time hey wait a bit harder
doesn't seem so bad anymore now that I
understand the mechanics of it instead
of flailing uselessly and having
everybody be upsetting me I'm oh okay
what is that why are there giant squares
on the screen what am I supposed to do
about you
okay this isn't part of the game oh is
it okay alright okay
oh come on mean fail don't tell me I
fall do I have to start up is that a
space potato all the meteors explode
into bits I could have died at any time
and I would have no idea because I
wouldn't even seen it now I owe you big
bug yes you are a big sassy [ __ ] am
well [ __ ] good for me
I gotta deflect most minor weapon how do
I use that
oh I don't get it okay I kind of get it
I get it I get it I get it I I'm just
being stupid about it I need to play
good not bad not be the embarrassment of
the Internet
there's that aspect that was a space
elephant for a second there it was
really freaking me out there okay so I'm
supposed to do that oh I can't make it
big enough that's what she said oh oh oh
you sassy sue ain't gonna get me okay
there we go I got one of them Oh God for
me supposed to do anything else oh I got
ya I killed one of them I don't know if
that means it's time for space ball
smooth and narrow that's how it's
supposed to be done
that's how other things are supposed to
be done too but you won't know about
that until you're older than me of
course officers
jaimé yo ah okay alright okay okay so
this turned into a bullet hell game but
I'm okay with that
okay okay what would I care no you don't
eat that no don't eat that well do you
think you're doing me oh yeah you're
doing with your bullets if your bullets
can affect me hey no you're not gonna
eat that
not today if I don't get killed by
stupidity was that a bomb do I want to
do that Oh give them the bomb Oh hate
life and you especially not actually I
like my life life is good life is great
you're just suck you're the definition
of ass you just generally are bad also
you smell bad explode except that
wouldn't go stale that one oh no you're
not dead come on how many of us rose to
win did I win I don't know what mm hang
on here's the problem my pants have been
on the whole time I got to take them off
and whatever
all right the pants are off and everyone
knows that you gained better without
pants it's just common knowledge so
let's try something else increased
targeting power that seems good now that
I can be intelligence up inside my brain
I should be fine all right bring it on
you this just boom does that mean I can
target a bigger space that is much
better
oh that is so much better targeting okay
service baseball of course it is why not
oh yeah we Billy Blanc er no oh what is
with that I don't even know what the
baseball term is for that but it's
stupid
another news the music's kind of nice
that's some okay Frick you try to be a
little kinder for the kids okay
nevermind no well I guess all my fun was
not meant to be had so I got a Phil peed
power cuz I mean when I got full okay
get out of here no thank you
oh yes yes yes
thought you could escape there nah
you're done son oh no it's the line now
I supposed to win no no no no no no no
no no no no no don't no no no no no aah
no no no no stop being dick is it son of
a [ __ ] those damn meteors they didn't
get me when I didn't know about him and
as soon as I started realizing that they
were actually there that's when I
started dying inside this mouse is
actually okay that's a ninja that's a
space ninja can tell me different it's a
space ninja wielding the master sword I
am NOT okay with this boo-boo what the
hell is that that's new
Oh what do I do about that okay all
right okay all right okay all right okay
oh yeah oh yeah uh-huh it's cool you're
all cool I think you're so cool you're
purple spaceships okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah I ran right into the
not live ones castle my rescue the
Fallen man no pilot is left behind I
wouldn't be so sure about that I'm
pretty sure that I'm gonna be very left
line okay are then these [ __ ] are
they even alive I die instantly as soon
as my spaceship is hit by a friggin
space ok never mock god damn it I came
in and finish my stupid joke
he's a stupid game is too stupid about
things you kidding me I got less score
than I got last time was this douchery
you can take your increased firepower
and you can shove it up your dong cuz I
don't even care anymore
whoa one I wanted three but ones okay
okay I got the perfect defense yeah tip
I don't want a tip go screw yourself my
PC screw yourself
oh oh really oh really this sass this
game sassing me how about you go screw
yourself game because I'm an expert
I'd be very hard game i beat vilasa box
here's an image of me beating philosoph
ox it's pretty incredible my life is
filled with the pain oh good is this
again I won I hate I hate I hate I just
hate a ship has been stranded protected
at all cost how about no I'm gonna
actually let it be blown up because
that's that's me it's what I do so it
okay
wow they get to die too come on come on
yo weed blood on me barking okey funky
oh don't shoot at me
no no oh
another tip huh oh I don't think so ha
ha ha ha what do we got for me oh my oh
no no no no you no no what is this Paul
oh this is a bunch of bull okay then
AutoKey BOS Natalija you think that's
quick
I've seen quicker things on my grandma
I've seen quicker snakes in a dick orgy
I'm cool I've seen I've seen quicker
elbows in a ferris bueller concert you
know what screw you I don't know I
didn't listen to you oh why why don't
you tell me before you blow up in my
face you know it's just common courtesy
it would really be nice if you don't
blame in my face I mean I just did my
hair well screw you okay so this game's
five bucks on Steam if you think that's
kind of steep well it is a good time
waster it will keep you challenged can
someone tally up the number of sexual
innuendos that were made in this video
because I'd really like to know write in
the comments if you wasted your time
counting that so either way thank you
all so much for watching click my
awesome games annotation list over there
it's in the description too there's like
a hundred different videos if you want
to check out the weird or strange or
cool games that I played in the past and
once again thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you
in the next week I'm just flipping
through channels at night getting the
high score all up in here
whoa what not on that drink dawg